I wonder if you've seen the front page
of the Daily Mirror today if not swella
bravaman has claimed nearly 25
000 pounds in five years for her London
home while living rent free with her
parents when not there now it's not
against the rules but it's stretching
them to the absolute limit especially
when people are struggling so much to
try and pay their bills at the moment
what do you say what would you say about
that
okay I hadn't seen that headline I don't
know the facts of that case
um I I don't think I can comment without
knowing any more I'm afraid well I can
tell you that her people have agreed
that that um has indeed been the case
they offered a defense as you would
expect but I mean the Optics are not
good when something like that happens
are they
well I think all of us in public life uh
when we have the uh privilege of
representing people in Parliament uh
have a duty to make sure that we spend
taxpayers money as wisely as possible uh
you know MPS have offices to run I think
people accept that that needs to be run
uh properly with supporting staff
um I I for instance share share
accommodation London with another MP try
and keep costs down uh I think all of us
need to be very mindful of the fact that
at this time of pressure for many
families we should do our bits to keep
costs as effective as possible and as
low as possible